maintenant pour la première questions
cribles thématiques à madame nathalie
goulet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'exercice
des questions crime est un peu difficile
sur un sujet aussi délicat
je suis aussi délicat et d'actualité
c'est pourquoi je voudrais vous
interroger sur une question prend pire
bien précises car notre politique dans
les pays arabes dépend en grande partie
de la qualité de notre personnel dans
ces pays je me suis entretenu il ya
quelques semaines avec une des proche
collaboratrice d'hillary clinton qui
pensaient qu'à l'aune des événements
actuels il fallait revoir complètement
le recrutement et l'implication du
personnel de nos ambassades
vous savez monsieur le ministre que de
très nombreux postes sont pourvus par
des gens qui ne parlent pas la langue du
pays
je pense notamment en matière d'attaché
culturel en matière de coopération je
crois que là nous avons de très grands
progrès à faire le récente attaché de
presse dans une ambassade des pays du
golfe ne parlant ni arabe ni anglais
interdire tout contact avec ces
populations
j'ai évidemment bien d'autres exemples
mais cela n'est pas utile aujourd'hui
j'aimerais savoir monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures vous comptez prendre
pour revoir ses erreurs de casting dans
notre politique étrangère est dans notre
pays n'a pas les moyens je remercie pour
répondre qui sur la parole est à
monsieur alain juppé ministre d'état
ministre des affaires étrangères et
européennes avaient la parole se choisit
laurent k mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame nathalie goulet ne suis pas
absolument sûr que les capacités
linguistiques de
me collègues diplomates américains
souhaitent aussi développer qu'on veut
bien le dire en très souvent en anglais
c'est vrai ce qui leur facilite le
travail je peux vous assurer que dans
notre politique de recrutement
nous essayons d'adapter plus possible
les profils et les postes très
simplement vous rendre attentifs au fait
que le taux de rotation au sein du
ministère des affaires étrangères est
l'un des plus élevé qu'on puisse
imaginer non seulement dans
l'administration mais tout simplement
dans la société française puisque un
tiers des agents titulaires et similé de
mon ministère change chaque année
d'affectation avec 7 tourne très vite
alors chaque fois nous essayons
d'adapter je le répète le profil au pot
c'est de tenir en particulier compte du
critère linguistique
la majorité des titulaires du ministère
des affaires étrangères qui sont en
fonction dans le golfe sont des
arabisants
je peux vous en donner quelques exemples
en arabie séoudite l'ambassadeur le
numéro deux le conseiller de coopération
et d'action culturelle le chef du
service commun de gestion le consul
général à djeddah et son adjoint sont de
parfaits arabisants au koweït c'est le
cas de notre ambassadrice l'ancien
interprète de la présidence de la
république que j'ai eu l'occasion de
bien connaître lorsque j'étais au quai
d'orsay à 15 ans maintenant ainsi que du
conseiller culturel et cela jointe au
qatar c'est le cas de l'ambassadeur du
numéro deux du numéro 3 ainsi que des
conseillers culturels d'envoyer
quelqu'un quand même beaucoup d'arabes
is an au quai d'orsay alors nous
essayons de développer tout cela je
ferai simplement de remarques
complémentaires
la première c'est que nous essayons de
développer dans l'accueil des diplomates
tout l'aspect formation linguistique et
c'est un des points qui avait été
soulignée par le livre blanc que j'avais
établi avec louis schweitzer ya deux ou
trois ans maintenant
deuxièmement que la rgpp qui réduit
considérablement nos moyens je dois le
dire nous incite à nous adresser à des
recrutés locaux et dans les recrutés
locaux évidemment le critère
linguistique tiens-tu de larges places
dont vous voyez que votre souci est pris
en considération comme sénateur oui
c'est pour ça qu'une mise au point et
une mise à jour des connaissances et est
nécessaire et moi je me félicite de
cette réponse qui a évolué au fur et à
mesure des questions que je posais
depuis des années mais
en ce qui concerne le collaborateur
d'hillary clinton elle m'indique est
elle même qui avait des efforts à faire
de son côté donc nous travaillons dans
le même sens dans l'intérêt de nos pays
respectifs et pour une meilleure
connaissance des pays dans lesquels nous
sommes implantés dans lesquelles nous
avons énormément de travail à faire
s'agissant de ces pays qui ont une
attente de la france très forte vous
remercie monsieur le ministre si ma
chère collègue la parole est maintenant
monsieur aymeri de montesquiou pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
la parole mon cher collègue maxime c'est
le président monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre d'état mes chers
collègues tous ceux qui affirmaient leur
certitude ont été totalement prise au
dépourvu par le printemps arabe des
contours du monde arabe sont connus mais
on perçoit mal son hétérogénéité sous
son unité religieuse on ne peut
comprendre cette réalité qu'à travers
notre prisme laïque sous peine d'une
erreur certaine certains parmi les
arabes aspirent un gouvernement laïc
mais dans le socle de leur société la
religion tient une place majeure ayant à
l'esprit que la force de la tradition
est supérieure à celle de la loi ce qui
est contraire à l'esprit démocratique
cependant gardons nous de toute
arrogance en supposant que ces pays ne
sont pas encore mûrs pour la démocratie
sir leur concept est encore très
éloignés de nos critères il évoluera des
élections vont se dérouler dans de
nombreux pays arabes
si les fondamentalistes musulmans les
emporte reconnaîtront nous les résultats
pour atteindre cet objectif l'union pour
la méditerranée avec sa rue barra ben
concrétise une tentative intéressante et
audacieuse mais elle est encore plus un
espoir qu'une réalité
quel est votre calendrier pour mener à
bien cette entreprise la ligue arabe
peut-elle devenir un partenaire
privilégié
une des difficultés majeures résident
dans les tensions entre israël et ses
voisins en particulier la syrie toléré
par certains gouvernements
israël n'a pas été acceptée par leurs
peuples dans leur quasi unanimité
pourquoi sans doute pour des motifs
historiques et religieux et par la
violence terrible des israéliens à
l'encontre les palestiniens depuis la
genèse de leur pays
l'existence d'israël est un fait elle
notait de protéger sa sécurité garantie
il on ne peut tolérer de sa part ce que
la communauté internationale interdit
aux autres les résolutions des nations
unies doit être appliqué le monde arabe
ressent comme profondément révoltante
cette justice internationale à géométrie
variable
la france est elle prête à mettre au
vote aux nations unies la reconnaissance
d'un état palestinien dans ses
frontières de 1967
étape indispensable pour aller vers la
paix si israël ne cède pas à cette
décision faut conclure et internationale
imaginons nous des sanctions ils ont la
parole et à monsieur alain juppé
ministre d'état ministre des affaires
étrangères devait la parole monsieur le
ministre d'état le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne se le
sénateur montesquiou je ne suis pas sûr
devoir répondre à deux minutes à autant
de questions pertinentes
je dirais simplement que ce qui se passe
au sud de la méditerranée et qu'il est
convenu d'appeler le printemps arabe que
nous n'avons peut-être pas pressenti est
une chance formidable et qu'il ne faut
pas en avoir peur lorsque voix des
peuples se lever pour la liberté pour la
démocratie pour les droits de l'homme
pour les droits de la femme
eh bien nous devons nous y engager sans
hésitation parce que c'est une façon de
retrouver avec eux une communauté de
valeurs ce principe étant posé ce que
nous essayons de faire c'est d'être
cohérent et de ne pas avoir deux poids
et deux mesures
et je voudrais le dire à propos de la
syrie parce que j'entends répéter ici ou
là que nous sommes indulgent avec ce qui
se passe en syrie
ce n'est pas exact nous avons pris une
position très claire préfère nous avons
condamné sans aucune espèce d'hésitation
l'utilisation de la violence par le
régime syrien contre sa population ce
qui est certain et c'est ce qui change
tout par rapport l'action que nous avons
menée s'agissant de la libye c'est qu'il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui au conseil de
sécurité un consensus sur la syrie les
grandes puissances telles que la russie
ou la chine menacent de faire usage de
leur droit de veto il n'y a même pas de
majorité de neuf mois pour se mettre
d'accord sur une résolution de
continuons à y travailler
troisième idée c'est que nous devons
être ouverts au dialogue
je les dis ça parfois un petit peu
surpris il faut parler avec ceux des
islamistes ou des islamique
qui récuse la violence et qui s'engagent
dans un processus démocratique
enfin quatrième point qui me paraît
essentiel si nous voulons que la
transition politique réussie ce dans des
pays comme l'egypte ou la tunisie nous
devons faire un effort massif pour les
aider sur le plan économique
si la crise économique se déclenche
comme cela menace bien sûr compte tenu
des contraintes que subissent ces pays
et bien il ya fort à parier que le
processus politique sera fragilisée
c'est ce que nous allons faire à
deauville en invitant l'egypte et la
tunisie pour mobiliser les grandes
puissances relancer aussi l'union pour
la méditerranée comme vous l'avez dit
enfin s'agissant d'israël et de la
palestine je ne répondrai pas par
anticipation à ce que nous ferons au
mois de septembre prochain je vous
dirais simplement que pour nous le
statut quo n'est pas possible et qu'il
nous faut donc exercer toute notre
action pour que le dialogue reprenne
entre israël et les palestiniens
merci monsieur le ministre l'état
monsieur montesquiou quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre d'état et vos
réponses nous sont très satisfaisantes
je partage cet optimisme pour le monde
arabe
il faut les aider économiquement il faut
avoir confiance en eux ne serait ce que
pour que les femmes retrouvent dans ces
pays leur dignité
quant à israël je crois que c'est quand
même une cause importante de conflit il
faut garantir la sécurité d'israël ni fo
demandent à israël de respecter la loi
internationale
merci parole est maintenant notre
collègue andré trillard pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre d'état
mais chers collègues aujourd'hui de
tunis au caire de misrata à sanaa les
peuples au prix d'un lourd tribut
écrivent une nouvelle page de leur
histoire
le profond changement de donne
consécutif aux événements du printemps
arabe appelle de notre part une
redéfinition de la politique envers les
états concernés
tout en se gardant de comparaison
simplificatrice quant aux situations
vécues par chacun d'entre eux évitons
également l'écueil qui consistera nous
positionner en vieilles puissances
moralisatrice forte de sa révolution
démocratique de plus âgés de plus de 200
ans
leur est plus grave en particulier en
libye en tant que président du groupe
france-libye au sénat dès le 21 février
dernier
me suis exprimée dès que les premiers
morts ont été connus dans le pays deux
mois plus tard le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies aux termes de la
résolution 1973 adoptée grâce à votre
détermination et votre savoir faire
monsieur le ministre donne tous les
moyens y compris militaires
la communauté internationale pour
protéger les populations civiles
libyennes
permettez moi de saluer ici l'action
conduite à l'initiative notre président
de la république qui a su après chacun
ses responsabilités mobiliser et fédérer
nos partenaires européens des
responsables de la ligue arabe
l'organisation du sommet pour le soutien
au peuple libyen le 19 mars en
témoignent combien de morts devrions
doute déploré aujourd'hui si on n'est
toujours pas intervenue
certains craignent l'enlisement un autre
afghanistan
mais le chemin sera long et difficile
ainsi que l'a dit moustafa abdel jalil
président du conseil national de
transition la liberté encore besoin de
temps pour l'emporter
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
vous nous esquissé les contours de la
future politique de la france dont
seulement les ennemis du conseil
national de transition mais également
sur le plan des échanges de l'aide de
l'accompagnement du peuple libyen vers
la démocratie
l'aspiration profonde symboliquement
illustré par l'aspect ce dimanche des 61
tribus à l'unité un acte tout à fait
historique pour ce pays
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur alain juppé ministre d'état
ministre des affaires étrangères avait
la parole monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le seul
sénateur trillard reportons-nous et
quelques semaines en arrière
et rappelons nous que si nous n'avions
pas fait ce que nous avons fait kadhafi
avait annoncé son intention de s'emparer
de benghazi et de se venger sur les
populations civiles de benghazi
c'était un risque de massacre de
plusieurs milliers de morts je pense que
nous avons fait notre devoir
deuxièmement aujourd'hui après avoir
continué à utiliser des armes lourdes
contre sa population
kadhafi est manifestement discréditer
ceux ci fait l'objet d'un consensus
c'est ce que pense l'union européenne
c'est ce que pense la ligue arabe
c'est ce que pensent des états unis
c'est ce que pense une grande partie des
pretty des pays de l'union africaine
pour arriver au résultat qui est de
permettre aux la population libyenne
d'affirmer ses droits et de mettre en
oeuvre une véritable démocratie dans une
libye nouvelle
nous agissons d'abord par la pression
militaire et nous avons décidé de
continuer parce que c'est le seul
langage hélas que kadhafi comprend d'où
à l'intensification des frappes que vous
connaissez avec le souci de rester dans
le cadre de la résolution 1973 et donc
de ne frappait que des cibles militaires
comme ça a été le cas lors de la
dernière frappes sur tripoli
deuxièmement nous accentuons aussi la
mise en oeuvre des sanctions mais nous
sommes bien conscients que au delà de
l'intervention militaire seule la
solution politique permettra de
déboucher sur la durée c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous travaillons un cessez
le feu qui en souhaitant et surtout à la
recherche d'une d'un dialogue politique
entre les différents acteurs
d'abord le conseil national de
transition que nous essayons de
renforcer mais aussi d'autres acteurs et
en particulier ceux qui à tripoli auront
compris qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir ni pour
eux ni pour la libye en restant
solidaires de kadhafi ça va être l'objet
de la réunion du prochain groupe de
contact à rome
jeudi prochain nous allons en
particulier travailler à un mécanisme
financier qui va permettre d'aider le
conseil national de transition mais
aussi ouvrir la voie à cette grande
rencontre de dialogue national qui nous
permettra je l'espère de déboucher sur
une solution politique démocratique
merci monsieur me défaire monsieur
trillard merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le ministre d'état déjà
appel que ce mouvement pour la liberté a
ébranlé des certitudes
selon lesquelles les régimes
autoritaires était un mal inévitable
pour contrer la montée de l'islamisme
sachant qu'il existe d'autres voies
qu'un choix binaire entre un tyran
laïque pare-feu des extrémistes et une
république islamiste
la relation de confiance qui s'instaura
entre la france et les pays en marche
vers la liberté dépendra largement de
notre capacité à comprendre les formes
diverses que prendra cette marche à les
accepter et à savoir que nous sommes en
appui est intéressé au combien par ce
mouvement qui me paraît profitable pour
tous
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
notre collègue jean louis carrère pour
le groupe socialiste
j'avais la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état un préambule liés à
l'actualité monsieur le ministre d'état
nous pensons que la disparation
d'oussama ben laden va constituer un
tournant dans notre tragique histoire
contemporaine
je demande solennellement que le sénat
puisse aborder la question de la
participation de notre pays à la guerre
en afghanistan
la question maintenant syrie libye iman
suivre l'exemple de la tunisie et de
l'egypte les peuples du monde arabe se
battent jour après jour pour plus de
liberté de justice
le maroc et l'algérie ne resteront pas
en marge de ce formidable mouvement
d'espoir nous avons soutenu
l'intervention militaire en libye elle
était juste et légitime
nous attendons maintenant une solution
politique elle tarde selon nous à venir
et nous fait craindre monsieur le
ministre d'état des risques d' escalade
voir d'enlisement
cette révolte des populations arabes a
des racines sociale très profonde très
profonde la démocratie et la justice
sociale sont au coeur de leur révolte
comment croire dès lors que l'on
pourrait soutenir avec générosité
ce printemps arabe qui ne doit pas nous
faire peur c'est vous que je cite si en
france en europe on claque la porte au
nez des migrants tunisiens ou libyens
qui cherchent un avro recomposer leurs
forces
solidaires à tunis à benghazi et au
caire mais pas à vintimille ou à paris à
l'épouvantail inacceptable que constitue
la posture du ministre de l'intérieur
je préfère vos propos sachant jouer tout
notre rôle fidèle à nos valeurs communes
de liberté de générosité et de respect
des droits de l'homme et de la femme
pour faire émerger avec le monde arabe
un espace de paix de stabilité des
changes en méditerranée alors vous
comprendrez ma question monsieur le
ministre d'état
quel est notre politique pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur alain
juppé ministre d'état ministre
affaires étrangères c'est la terre c'est
le sénateur carrière juste un mot sur
votre introduction comme vous je pense
que la disparition de ben laden est
porteuse de beaucoup de conséquences
positives je ne suis pas sûr que le
moment soit déjà venu de considérer
qu'il faut se retirer d'afghanistan
le terrorisme n'a pas disparu les
réseaux terroristes en afghanistan n'ont
pas disparu et donc prenons le temps de
la réflexion avant d'agir sur les
différents pays que vous avez cités je
crois qu'il est très important en ayant
la même attitude d'ouverture vers tous
ceux qui se battent pour la liberté la
démocratie d'adapter notre politique en
fonction des circonstances
la situation du yémen n'est pas celle de
la libye et celle du maroc n'est pas
celle de l'algérie au yémen j'espère que
la médiation du conseil de coopération
des états du golfe va aboutir salle est
fallu de peu il ya quelques jours aux
crocs je reste confiant dans
l'initiative prise par le roi et qui est
une grande ouverture vers une monarchie
réellement constitutionnel votre
question pose plus particulière porte
plus particulièrement sur la question
des migrants et des réfugiés
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que nous
avons fortement aider au retour des
réfugiés égyptiens qui ont quitté la
libye
en organisant un pont aérien et un pont
maritime pour leur permettre de revenir
dans leur pays comme il le souhaitait en
ce qui concerne les relations avec la
tunisie de ce point de vue j'ai
l'occasion de pande entretenir de
manière très des passionnés avec le
premier ministre le président de la
république les milices des affaires
étrangères nos partenaires comprennent
très bien que le flux d'immigration
irrégulière est un fléau pour eux comme
pour nous comme pour les intéressés qui
sont victimes d'une véritable traite et
ils ont donc accepté avec désormais le
concours de l'union européenne puisque
le président barroso vient de répondre
très positivement à la lettre que lui
avait adressé monsieur berlusconi et le
président sarkozy
ils sont donc des styles décidé à nous
aider à contrôler mieux les frontières
et à réadmettre sur leur territoire des
personnes qui ne sont pas victimes de
persécution politique par définition et
qui ne sont donc pas des réfugiés
pour ce qui concerne les réfugiés nous
examinons les situations à la lumière
des règles des traités que nous avons
souscrit je voulais voir rappeler
simplement qu'il y a en france 50 mille
demandeurs du droit d'asile
il y en a dix mille à l'italie
on fait valoir auprès des autorités
italiennes enfin lorsque vous considérez
que les prises de position de monsieur
guéant vous choque je ne suis évidemment
pas de cet avis je vous ai dit que nous
avons été entendus au niveau de la
commission européenne dans la lettre que
monsieur barroso vient d'adresser je
terminerai par répété très brièvement ce
que j'ai déjà dit ici je crois c'est de
la vraie solution n est pas là d'un vrai
solution elle est dans la réduction des
inégalités entre le nord et le sud s'est
taillé dans une politique puissante
continue dans le cadre de l'union pour
la méditerranée et au delà qui
permettent à ces pays de se développer
et de permettre à leurs jeunes de faire
ce dont ils rêvent vraisemblablement
c'est à dire rester au pays dans la
liberté et dans le progrès économique
merci monsieur le ministre d'état
monsieur carrère
je n'ai ni la volonté ni la naïveté de
croire que je pourrais vous opposer à
tel ou tel ministre du gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez
néanmoins je vous le dis avec beaucoup
d'honnêteté aussi je préfère la manière
dont vous exprimer les choses à certains
autres façons de les exprimer
c'est le seul commentaire que j'avais à
faire et je pense que la france gagnera
en rayonnement à les exprimer comme vous
venez de le faire par rapport à d'autres
expressions que je continue de contester
de compagnie merci mon cher collègue la
parole et notre collègue robert hue
selon ghazi des ministres républicain
citoyen messenger il est à gauche mais
j'ai appelé lègue au delà du thème de
notre débat de ce soir comme mon
prédécesseur je veux dire que
l'événement que constitue la mort de ben
laden et ses conséquences mériterait un
débat parlementaire que avec mon groupe
je sollicite sans délai le coup majeur
porté à ce symbole du terrorisme
mondialisé nécessite notamment de
définir enfin je l'affirmé aussi les
conditions du retrait de nos troupes et
de celle de l'automne d'afghanistan j'en
viens à la question précise de ce soir
monsieur le ministre d'état à l'occasion
d'un récent colloque à l'institut du
monde arabe vous avez exposé les
nouvelles orientations de la politique
extérieure de la france à l'égard du
monde arabo musulman
je souhaiterais que vous m'apportez deux
précisions concernant la tunisie
d'entre elles a été évoqué un instant
vous avez annoncé lors de votre
déplacement à tunis que la france ferait
un important effort financier en
accordant une aide de 350 millions
d'euros
notre aide bilatérale est évidemment
essentiel pour accompagner le
développement économique et la
transition démocratique de ce pays je ne
la négligent pas du tout mais la tunisie
doivent faire face à une situation socio
économique catastrophique en plus des
sommes astronomiques détourné par le
clan ben ali le poids de sa dette
extérieure compromet dangereusement la
possibilité d'une relance de son
économie
en conséquence quelles initiatives
comptez-vous prendre auprès de nos
partenaires pour suspendre le
remboursement des créances européennes
sur la tunisie en second lieu où on se
nouent des négociations avec les
autorités tunisiennes
vous l'avez abordé pour adapter à la
nouvelle situation l'accord dit de
gestion les flux migratoires que nous
avions signé en 2008 les rails la
réactivation de cet accord permettrait
ainsi d'apporter un début de solution
juste et humaine à l'afflux d'émigrants
auxquels nous sommes confrontés pour
vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur alain juppé
ministre d'état ministre des affaires
étrangères messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur robert hue
comme vous le savez je me suis rendue en
tunisie il y a quelques jours
et j'ai été frappé par la qualité de
l'accueil que j'ai reçu
d'abord par les autorités tunisiennes
elles mêmes le premier ministre le
président de la république le ministre
des affaires étrangères mais aussi dans
la rue je suis allé dans le choc de la
médina de tunis
on m'avait beaucoup dit que le drapeau
français n'y était mal vu ce n'est pas
du tout ce que j'ai ressenti
bien au contraire et pas davantage dans
l'entretien que j'ai pu avoir avec ce
qu'on appelle les blogueurs c'est à dire
cette jeunesse qui est sur internet et
qui a joué un rôle si décisif dans la
propagation de ce mouvement
révolutionnaire
alors il faut aider la tunisie c'est
tout à fait vrai parce que le processus
politique est bien en route les
élections du 24 juillet qui vont
permettre d'élire une assemblée
constituante sont bien préparés une
commission électorale est en train de
définir une future loi électorale j'ai
eu contact avec le président de cette
commission qui me fait très bonne
impression
le défi économique considérable le
tourisme s'est effondré les réfugiés en
provenance de libye sont nombreux il y à
des camps de réfugiés à la frontière
entre la libye et la tunisie
et puis les populations attendent un
mieux-être de la révolution il ya donc
des exigences sociales très fortes
il faut donc une aide massive c'était
les bilatérales vous l'avez rappelé 350
millions des de l' agence française de
développement immédiatement disponible
elle est européenne nous travaillons
avec nos partenaires européens pour
mobiliser les fonds européens destinés à
la politique de voisinage et aux
partenariats en méditerranée nous
travaillons aussi à la relance de
l'union pour la méditerranée et puis
enfin nous attendons beaucoup comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure de la réunion du
g8
nous aurons là les principales
puissances économiques du monde et
l'idée c'est de mettre en place très
rapidement une procédure qui va nous
permettre d'élaborer un plan d'action en
faveur de la tunisie est en faveur de
l'egypte qui aura le soutien de
l'ensemble des partenaires du g8
en ce qui concerne les migrations claude
guéant on continue son travail avec les
autorités tunisiennes et de nous
orientons vers un accord inspiré de ce
qui a été conclu avec l'italie c'est à
dire un renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières nous allons aider avec
frontex les tunisiens à contrôler leurs
portes frontières faut bien voir que
l'effondrement de leurs systèmes de
sécurité de leur police n'est pas pour
rien dans ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
d'autre part
nous allons aussi travailler à un accord
de réadmission dans le même esprit que
ce qui a été conclu avec l'italie
voilà dans quel but donc nous
travaillons en ce moment
sans oublier ce que j'ai répondu tout à
l'air bien sûr aux sénateurs carrère si
on verrue oui brièvement monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre d'état
bien sûr je suis effectivement satisfait
d'un certain nombre d'aspects que vous
venez d'évoquer je veux dire qu'en
tunisie
ce n'est pas le drapeau de la france qui
était rejeté c'est les détestables
relations qu'il y avait entre les
gouvernements précédents et monsieur ben
ali et sa politique mais j'en reviens à
des représentants légaux problème des
flux migratoires des représentants de la
tunisie sont venus aussi ces derniers
temps en france et souhaite la
renégociation de ces accords a priori le
gouvernement français oscille je pense
que selon les rapports des accords
bilatéraux mais je crois qu'il est
urgent que s'engage cette démarche et
cette conclusion d'accords nouveau parce
que c'est il dépend beaucoup y compris
de l'évolution démocratique de ce pays
qui est confronté à des difficultés
sociales majeures que ces accords
existent et aide à la démocratie merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
bernard fournier pour le groupe e union
pour un mouvement populaire
mais la parole monsieur le président
monsieur ministre d'état monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mes
collègues l'ont dit avant moi
2011 restera une année historique pour
le maghreb soulèvement révolution et
changement de régime bouleverse les
cartes jusqu'aux confins du moyen-orient
ces évolutions se font au prix du sang
de la répression mais aussi son
empreinte d'espoir l'espoir auxquelles
nous devons répondre sans l'aider soir
ma question concerne la tunisie le payer
on est à son quatrième gouvernement
il semble que la population ne souffre
aucune concession vis à vis des anciens
responsables politiques ayant appartenu
au régime ben ali au pouvoir pendant
trente ans il est à craindre que ce qui
devait s'apparenter à une transition
démocratique ne devienne une crise
titus ionel pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre quel soutien notre
pays peut-il apporter aux tunisiens pour
les aider dans cette résurrection
démocratique
par ailleurs cette semaine le président
de la banque mondiale se rend en tunisie
il est primordial que le pays puisse
sortir d'un système économique fondé
uniquement sur le tourisme de masse
la tunisie doit aujourd'hui répondre aux
besoins de sa jeunesse dont une grande
partie est diplômé comme l'illustrent
notre tradition des échanges
universitaires pour autant bon nombre de
ces jeunes sont au chômage
lors du déplacement des 20 et 21 avril
dernier à tunis le ministre des affaires
étrangères a annoncé la mobilisation de
350 millions d'euros sous forme de prêts
bilatéraux
mercredi dernier vous même monsieur le
ministre vous avez reçues les ministre
tunisien des finances du commerce et du
tourisme de la formation professionnelle
et de l'emploi
je me réjouis de cet entretien pluriel
car il témoigne d'une vision globale
pour relancer l'économie nationale
tunisienne incluant les facteurs de
développement socio- toutefois pouvez
vous nous préciser si un calendrier ou
des évaluations seront mis en place afin
d'accompagner au mieux ce pays
je vous remercie pour répondre d'un
parole et pts monsieur henri de
raincourt ministre chargé de la
coopération de la parole je vous
remercie monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
évidemment répondre précisément à la
question qui a été posée par votre
collègue monsieur bernard fournier mais
je m'inspire aussi de ce qui a été dit
un certain nombre d'entre vous qui sur
ce même sujet très important et auquel
évidemment nous sommes très attachés
il a été répondu il s'agit bien de la
tunisie
donc c'est vrai après les événements qui
se sont passés une certaine instabilité
gouvernementale s'est manifesté vous
avez rappelé vous même qu'on en est est
aujourd'hui 4e gouvernent
le mans je peux vous dire que le
ministre d'état comme il vous l'a
expliqué tout à l'heure s'est rendu
lui-même en tunisie et qu' il a pu
rencontrer aussi bien le président de la
république que le mais le premier
ministre les différents ministres
concernés et que aujourd'hui nous avons
une équipe gouvernementale de très haut
niveau
expérimenté et de très haut niveau et
j'ai moi même reçu comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même
plusieurs ministres que ce soit celui
des finances du commerce du tourisme la
formation professionnelle de l'emploi
des transports et de l'équipement tout
ce sont des chefs d'entreprise ou sont
issues de secteurs professionnels qui
l'ont quitté momentanément pour servir
leur pays dans cette période essentielle
d'une transition réussie qui doit
conduire aux élections législatives
comme cela a été indiqué tout à l'heure
et c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui la france monsieur le
sénateur ne craint pas d'aidé d'une
manière je crois substantielle nos amis
tunisiens à repartir du bon pied d'abord
parce qu'il y à beaucoup d'éléments qui
sont positifs
bien sûr qu'ils doivent redémarrer mais
aussi parce que aussi bien sur le plan
économique que sur le plan politique que
sur le plan diplomatique aujourd'hui
nous avons des perspectives qui sont
positives et je termine en disant que
sur le plan diplomatique nous militons à
fond pour le statut avancé pour la
tunisie et sur le plan politique nous
travaillons dans le détail ainsi que sur
le plan financier voilà simplement ce
que je peux vous dire en deux minutes
c'est un peu court mais avec nous soyez
confiants pour l'avenir de la tunisie
parce qu'ils reposent d'abord entre les
mains des tunisiens
merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur fournier
simplement je voudrais remercier
monsieur le ministre pour les précisons
qu'il a bien voulu nous apporter et qui
vont dans le sens que nous pouvions
souhaité je vous remercie
mais si la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue dame monique cerisier ben guiga
pour le groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole ma question porte
sur l'état de nos relations avec la
syrie
je crains qu'aujourd'hui en dépit de ces
efforts la france ne paient les choix
calamiteux du début du quinquennat que
le président sarkozy ait renforcé
renouer les résident les relations avec
les pires dictateurs arabes kadhafi
bachar el-assad et l'aurait rendu ainsi
une légitimité internationale était une
erreur
rétablir des liens avec la série en
marge de la diplomatie officielle
aussi ai je rappelle les innombrables
mission de claude guéant secrétaire
général de l'elysée à damas en quoi ont
consisté les accords passés ainsi hors
de tout contrôle avec le parlement nous
voudrions savoir dans quelle mesure il
pèse sur la politique actuelle en
apparence aujourd'hui la politique
française a changé du tout au tout et
nous approuvons totalement le vote de la
résolution du conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu qui demande à la syrie
de mettre un terme à la violation des
droits de l'homme contre son peuple et
qui met en place une commission denquête
de même monsieur de même nous approuvons
les déclarations du ministre des
affaires étrangères et celle du
représentant permanent de la france
auprès des nations unies
toutefois face à une répression qui a
pris la forme d' acte de guerre
caractérisé contre les habitants des
villes de deraa douma banias centre
autres et d'arrestations massives ces
deux derniers jours nous estimons que la
france doit aller au delà des
déclarations
est ce que le gouvernement entend
prendre en france des mesures
contraignantes pour assad son entourage
les responsables de la répression en
atteignant leurs avoirs financiers leur
propriété et en empêchant leur entrée
sur notre territoire
quelle section quelle sanction défendre
et vous aux prochaines réunions du
conseil de sécurité
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur henri de raincourt ministre
chargé de la coopération
vous pouvez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame le sénateur
je pense que la période à laquelle vous
faites référence qui n'est pas aussi
éloignés étaient fondamentalement
différente de celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
ce qui justifie me semble-t-il que la
position du gouvernement français à
l'époque utt différentes
il s'agit bien de discuter d'état à état
et quand on a la préoccupation d'essayer
modestement de contribuer à ce que un
environnement favorable à la paix puisse
se créer dans cette partie du monde je
vois pas comment on peut faire quand on
pense en particulier au liban pour
éviter de discuter avec la syrie et ceci
n'est jamais dépassé ce qu'il est
convenu de deux nécessaires en matière
de relations diplomatiques
nous sommes jamais allés au delà
deuxièmement madame sur la situation
d'aujourd'hui la france condamne sans
réserve de la manière la plus solennelle
toutes les violences toutes les
exactions et la france a demandé à la
syrie de cesser ces violences nous avons
convoqué l'ambassadrice de syrie à paris
et la réciproque s'est déroulée à damas
deuxièmement nous essayons de mobiliser
sans succès jusqu'à maintenant autour de
nous au niveau du conseil de sécurité
vous avez fait référence au conseil des
droits de l'homme
nous partageons le même sentiment nous
militons pour que la candidature de la
syrie ne soient pas acceptés et
troisièmement parce que le temps presse
au sein de l'union européenne il a donc
été décidé de travailler à des sanctions
fortes je précise mise en place d'un
embargo sur les armes gel de l'accord
d'association révision de la politique
de coopération entre l'union européenne
et la syrie et des sanctions
individuelles
contre les responsables de la répression
sanglante de ces dernières semaines
je peux vous assurer madame que le
gouvernement français n'a pas à l'égard
de la syrie
une position différente de celle qu'ils
expriment dans ce printemps des peuples
pour plus de liberté et plus de dignité
merci monsieur le ministre
voilà monsieur régis avec mia c'est bien
entendu votre réponse monsieur ministre
et je n'ai jamais mis en cause les
prises de position de la france
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que entre
les prises de position verbales et des
actes il y à un espace qu'il faut franck
il faut passer je crois que dès
maintenant les biens et les avoirs de
tous les responsables syriens en france
doivent être gelée cela concerne
directement le général mais nafila ce
responsable des exactions à bagnas je
pense que la diplomatie de connivence
qui était un peu la règle ces derniers
temps de la france à damas doit
absolument prendre fin et enfin la
france doit demander au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu la comparution de
bachar el-assad et des responsables de
la répression devant la cour pénale
internationale
merci ma chère collègue aurait d'abord
remercier monsieur le ministre remercié
le ministre d'état pour les réponses qui
ont été apportées aux questions des
collègues sénateurs
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 18 heures pour la
suite de la discussion des propositions
de loi sur le risque de submersion
marine nation c'est donc suspendu
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat mais
pour prolonger la discussion de ces
questions cribles thématiques consacre
aujourd'hui à la france et à la
situation politique dans le monde arabe
j'accueille à mes côtés robert hue
sénateur groupe communiste du val d'oise
bonjour bonjour alors vous vous
inquiétez de l'état des accords de
coopération entre la france et la
tunisie
pourtant récemment christine lagarde
indiqué qu'il y aura renforcement de la
coopération économique
il ya 350 millions d'euros qui vont être
débloqués dette bilatérale
parce que c'est insuffisant selon vous
il faut aller plus loin oui il faut
aller plus loin et ce que j'ai rappelé à
monsieur le ministre d'état tout à
l'heure c'est aussi que entre le moment
où nous avons été convoqués pour ces
questions et aujourd'hui il ya eu la
mort de ben laden et qu'en toute
circonstance compte tenu des
conséquences énormes que représente
cette mort il convient je crois je les
demande et vous l'avez noté qu'il y ait
un débat parlementaire sur cette
question ça me semble essentiel j'en
viens à la question concernant la
tunisie
le monsieur juppé lors d'un colloque je
crois à l'institut du monde arabe il y à
quelques temps rappelé ce qu'était la
nouvelle politique extérieure de la
france concernant le monde arabo
musulman
j'entends bien et qui lie à ses 350
millions d'êtres bilatérales entendez
naturellement le bilatéral mais il me
semble que il faut aller plus loin il
faut voir l'état actuel de la tunisie sa
dette notamment les sommes qu'ils ont
été
dilapidé placés à l'étranger par le clan
ben ali est dans ces conditions il me
semble que nos partenaires et nous mêmes
devrions examiner sans délai la
possibilité d'un moratoire voire d'un
report des créances de la tunisie ça
c'est la première idée
la deuxième idée que je veux indiquer
que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure il
s'agit des flux migratoires c'est très
important mais ces flux migratoires ils
ont déjà fait l'objet d'un accord en
2008 entre la france et la tunisie
donc la question que j'ai posée à
monsieur juppé est naturellement ça a
son importance c'est quid aujourd'hui de
ces flux migratoires d accord sur tout
voilà les éléments importants on a
appris aujourd'hui qu'il ya 72 migrants
tunisiens qui ont été interpellées à
nice ce qu'elle doit être la position de
la france est la position de la france
elle doit se définir en fonction
précisément des accords qui ont été
passés avec nos partenaires dans
l'ancienne période
a fortiori aujourd'hui dans la situation
politique nouvelle
on a parlé un de sol et économique il ya
également le volet de démocratique
comment peut-on accompagner la tunisie
vers l'art une voie démocratique sans
faire de l'ingérence en écoute et je
crois que la voie démocratique pour la
tunisie passe par la question convient
d'examiner ensemble c'est aux tunisiens
eux mêmes de définir les conditions
démocratiques dans lesquelles ils
doivent se donner les moyens d'un choix
de gouvernance mais en même temps on
voit bien que cette ses choix
démocratique vont tout de suite est
hypothéquée par la situation économique
sociale du pays
nous le voyons bien c'est naturel donc
dans ces conditions je crois que l'une
des questions démocratiques posée au
delà des conseils entre guillemets parce
qu'on en a trop donné des conseils pour
aboutir à des choix qui n'était point
démocratique le peuple a
du justement je un verdict je parle du
peuple tunisien à ce propos mais
aujourd'hui il faut cette coopération
économique sociale
c'est le meilleur chemin pour que la
démocratie puisse voir le jour dans une
bonne condition en tunisie vous avez
wauquiez au début de cette interview la
mort de ben laden cela relance également
la question de l'apprendre présence
française en afghanistan est ce que les
troupes françaises doivent rester mais
écoutez je crois que ce qui vient de se
passer dans le monde avec la mort de ben
laden
je disais tout à l'heure que je
souhaitais qu'il y ait un débat
parlementaire
mais précisément pour que à l'issue de
ce débat parlementaire on prennent enfin
en compte la situation en afghanistan et
que l'on quitte l'afghanistan ainsi que
les forces de l'automne n'a pas dans
n'importe quelles conditions c'est
évident il faut créer les conditions
adaptées de d'un départ mais maintenant
il est urgent oui que la france quitte
l'afghanistan
merci robert hue d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'accueille maintenant un
autre sénateur le sénateur aymeri de
montesquiou bonjour merci de répondre
aux questions de public sénat dont vous
êtes sénateur rds du gers alors vous
vous inquiétez sur les moyens d'asseoir
les transitions la transition
démocratique dans le monde arabe après
ces révolutions est-ce qu'il faut que
cela passe obligatoirement par l'upm
l'union pour la méditerranée qu'il faut
relancer
je crois que l'upm est un socle très
intéressant pour coopérer de part et
d'autre de la méditerranée
il est évident que les flux migratoires
ont des conséquences importantes dans
l'union européenne
donc il faut tarir ses fumées
migratoires et tout le monde est
d'accord que ça ne peut se faire qu'en
créant de l'emploi de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ça c'est à soc extrêmement
important nous avons d'autres
interrogations
par exemple il va y avoir des élections
face à tant de pays et on s'en réjouit
quelle doit être l'attitude de la france
si ce sont des ventes fondamentalistes
musulmans qui emporte sélection au début
des années 90 lorsque le fils avait
gagner les élections en algérie eh bien
on s'est dit opposé lorsque le hamas a
gagné les élections à gaza alors que il
y avait des centaines d'observateurs qui
ont jugé que les élections s'étaient
passées de façon normale
eh bien on a refusé ce résultat donc à
une véritable interrogation c'est un
risque selon vous que les
fondamentalistes reviennent ils viennent
au pouvoir en tunisie
écoutez je connais mal la tunisie on a
vu quelques manifestations l'a vu aussi
des infirmations de ses ventes à
mentalist en disant que c'était tout à
fait ouvert à démocratie il est certain
que la religion une place particulière
dans le monde arabe et que très souvent
la tradition prend le pas sur la loi ce
qui est contraire à la démocratie mais
il faut néanmoins aider au maximum tous
ces pays est un des moyens qui apparaît
évident à tout le monde c'est justement
le développement de l'économie et la
france a eu raison d'aider la tunisie
financièrement pour que son économie ne
partent pas la dérive c'est un point
très important
il ya aussi une interrogation dans le
cadre de l'union pour la méditerranée
cet israël
il faut absolument que israël accepte de
mettre en application les résolutions de
l'onu
il faut qu'israël accepte partenaires un
voisin palestinien
il faut en contrepartie bien entendu que
la communauté internationale
garantissent la sécurité d'israël la
france doit d'intervenir de la même
façon en tunisie en égypte on peut
imaginer également en libye en syrie
après le départ de kadhafi ou du
président bachar al assad ya d'abord la
volonté d'appuyer tout mouvement
démocratique mais il est évident que au
niveau d'une intervention militaire
eh bien on ne pourra pas faire plus que
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui en libye
nous servons été autorisée par les
nations unies nous avons un accord avec
la ligue arabe et je le répète la ligue
arabe doit être un partenaire
extrêmement important malgré sa
diversité bien que certains deux des
participants
correspondent pas à notre concept la
démocratie je pense que c'est un lien
extrêmement utile avec tout le monde
arabe
merci aymeri de montesquiou d'avoir
répondu aux questions de public sénat
tout de suite nous retrouvons le studio
avec orianne mancini et mickaël szames s
pour une édition spéciale consacrée à
l'hommage des victimes des attentats de
marrakech très bonne soirée à tous merci
beaucoup delphine et bonjour à tous
bienvenue sur les chaînes parlementaires
pour cette édition spéciale dans
quelques minutes nicolas sarkozy va
prononcer un discours sur le terrorisme
le président de la république est en ce
moment même à l'aéroport d'orly où il
accueille les dépouilles à des victimes
françaises de l'attentât de marrakech un
attentat qui a eu lieu jeudi dernier sur
la place jemaa el fna le coeur
touristique de marrakech
un attentat qui a fait 16 morts et 21
blessés
durant son discours nicolas sarkozy va
aussi bien sûr s'exprimer pour la
première fois sur la mort d'oussama ben
laden
c'est barack obama lui même qui a
annoncé hier matin la mort du chef d'al
qaïda et cerveau des attentats du 11
septembre
cela faisait à 10 ans que les états unis
elle traque est leur ennemi public
numéro un
il a donc été tué au pakistan il hier
matin lors d'une opération commando être
des américains
nous allons commenter cette actualité
avec les invités qui vont nous rejoindre
sur le plateau dans quelques instants
jean louis bruguière l'ancien juge anti
terroriste et eric laurent journaliste
spécialiste de politique internationale
et auteur de la face cachée du 11
septembre
mais pour commencer un mickaël szames s
est avec nous sur le plateau bonjour
notre éditorialiste politique
alors on le voit sur les images l'avion
transportant est les dépouilles des huit
victimes françaises de l'attentât de
marrakech a atterri à orly il ya
maintenant près d'une heure elle nicolas
sarkozy est déjà là bas qu'est ce qui se
passe à orly en ce moment même pour la
vue sur ces images c'est d'abord il ya
près d'une heure les cercueils sont
arrivés sur le tarmac d'orly par l'avion
un avion affrété par la présidence de la
république française pour l'instant les
familles ce recueil avec les corps des
victimes
dans un second temps nicolas sarkozy
fera son discours qui devrait durer
entre dix et quinze minutes et ensuite
nicolas sarkozy y rencontrera les
familles des victimes comme il en a
l'habitude comme il en a l'usagé
quand il ya des morts à l'extérieur à
l'étranger victimes des attentats
nicolas sarkozy le président de la
république française s'exprimera et
s'adressera évidemment aux familles avec
sûrement beaucoup de compassion on peut
l'imaginer une discussion qui aura lieu
à huis clos on attend bien le sourire
on attendait là le discours de nicolas
sarkozy discours que vous suivrez en
direct dans quelques minutes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
alors michael que peut-on attendre de ce
discours du président d'alors comme je
vous le disais beaucoup de compassion va
sûrement beaucoup parlé des attentats
qui ont touché marrakech
évidemment qui ont touché les français
et pas seulement parce qu'il ya aussi
d'autres nationalités qui ont été
touchés il va aussi parler du terrorisme
le terrorisme ces anneaux à thème sur
lequel nicolas sarkozy est attendu
il va le répéter depuis les années 80 la
france a toujours été touchée par le
terrorisme
que ce soit des prises d'otages ou
encore des attentats à paris on a été
touchés des années 80 dans les années 90
et il va affirmer aussi les grands
principes qui tiennent comme un étendard
pour pour la france ces grands principes
c'est d'abord la fermeté il faut
toujours être ferme avec les terroristes
pas négociations ne cède pas dit il au
combat les terroristes il n'y a pas de
compromis possible avec eux et les
démocraties n'y a pas de juste milieu
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a dit dans
une interview à paraître demain dans le
magazine l'express dont on a pu lire
quelques moments forts quelques moments
clés quatre pages d'interview sur lequel
il revient sur son action en tant que
chef de l'état mais bien sûr sur la
politique étrangère de la france
et bien sûr évidemment du terrorisme il
sera sûrement aussi question de ben
laden même si on ne sait pas encore
selon l'elysée s'il ne nous nous sommes
à ben laden sera précisée ou pas c'est
important mais il aura sûrement quelques
allusions et il a confirmé il l'a dit à
barack obama il ya peu de temps il a dit
que c'etait un
succès historique mais qui ne signifie
pas la fin d'al qaïda
évidemment on prend beaucoup de mesures
il faut être mesuré certes oussama ben
laden n'est plus mais al qaïda demeure
et son idéologie aussi et le combat
contre les criminels criminels dit il
qui s'en réclament doit rassembler tous
les états et notamment les musulmans qui
sont confrontés à ce fléau c'est à dire
aujourd'hui
il ouvre le chemin vers un monde de
dialogue et c'est peut-être ce qui est à
noter dans ce futur discours qu'on
risque d'entendre d'ici quelques minutes
c'est cette ouverture vers le monde
musulman et vers ce printemps musulmans
qu'on a connu ces derniers temps là il
devra sûrement quelques références à
faire alors vous l'avez évoqué michael
un nicolas sarkozy donne une longue
interview dans l'express à paraître
demain et pour en savoir un petit peu
plus nous sommes en ligne avec christian
makarian ans le directeur délégué de la
rédaction de l'express
bonjour monsieur ma carrière bonsoir
vous avez rencontré le chef de l'état
qui vous a donc donné une longue
interview sur la politique étrangère de
la france
on y revient dans quelques secondes avec
michael mais d'abord première question
que vous a dit nicolas sarkozy sur la
mort d'oussama ben laden
alors il exprimé notamment parce que
l'interview a eu lieu juste avant
l'annoncé de la mort d'oussama ben laden
en revanche par un contact ultérieure
nous avons pu poser la question au
président et il a effectivement prononcé
la phrase que vous voulez des cités
savoir que c'était évidemment une très
grande
très grand succès historique la phrase
qui cite que de s'être défait de la
personne d'oussama ben laden et de ses
nuisances mais qu'en revanche évidemment
le spectre d'al qaïda continuer de peser
sur le terrorisme international
voilà donc il n'a pas été très disert au
sujet d'oussama ben laden en orge et
colas sarkozy s'est très longuement
exprimé de façon extrêmement catégorique
sur le terrorisme international qui l'a
condamné de plusieurs manières et ilan a
proposé d'ailleurs une solution à
travers toutes ces crises qui
aboutissent assez grand soulèvement à ce
qu'on appelle ce qui est convenu
d'appeler désormais des révolutions
arabes
il y voit la seule manière d'éradiquer
le terrorisme dans les pays musulmans à
travers le développement à travers le
progrès à travers aussi la liberté
d'expression qui est l'ennemi de
l'obscurantisme
en matière de politique étrangère on
sent peut-être dans cette interview vous
l'avez peut-être noté par un mot clé
encore une fois c'est le mot rupture est
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une rupture
et que ses prédécesseurs
alors une école à sarkozy a développé de
façon très conceptuel ce point et il
agissait à ce sujet quelques il a voulu
le dire il faut dire que du général de
gaulle à jacques chirac tous ses
prédécesseurs
suivait un maître mot en matière de
politique étrangère
appliquée à la méditerranée un bien
entendu ce mot c'est celui de stabilité
il veut en finir avec ce concept l'ap
il considère qu au nom de la stabilité
en a parfois soutenues des dictatures
afin d'éviter les troubles et les
désordres ce qui nous a conduit
notamment à la position en a tant décrié
lorsque la tunisie et soulevait contre
ben ali
donc justement que sur moi-même vous
noté là une vraie différence que ce soit
avec de gaulle ou